[Music]
imagine
having the ability to live forever
travel anywhere in the universe and
harness enough power
to create wormholes
well if you're part of the ultra
exclusive
type 3 civilization club these are just
some of the everyday luxuries available
so how could feeble earthlings
get to this level of power but
more importantly should we even try
how would our lives transform as a type
3 civilization
would technology work for us or
against us and what would it take to get
to a type 4 civilization
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we were a type 3 civilization
on the kardashev scale which measures a
civilization's
technological ability to harness energy
we're stuck at a type zero
to graduate to type one we'd have to
take
full advantage of all the earth's energy
and any energy that comes our way such
as
sunlight according to physicist michio
kaku
we'll get there in a century or two
but to get to type 2 where we're able to
harness
all the energy of our sun dr kaku
estimates
we're a few thousand years away which
is frankly pretty optimistic to reach
type 3 where a civilization harnesses
the power of its
entire galaxy michio estimates that
we're looking at anywhere from 100 000
to 1 million years
so if we managed to fast
forward 1 million years into the future
what would our lives look like
with the ability to harness nearly
limitless energy from
any planet or star within sight we could
live
anywhere we wanted maybe we could build
an even better earth or an entirely new
solar system
from scratch looking for a tropical
beach
planet it's all yours or how about
a mushroom planet sure we can do that
earth mars and every planet in our solar
system
might just be husks at this point we
would have
mined them of all their resources to
build dyson swarms
no i'm not talking about a swarm of
fancy vacuums but
millions of energy collecting satellites
that could swarm
around a star and turn it into one big
battery but to truly become
a type 3 civilization we'd need swarms
of dyson swarms
collecting an unfathomable amount of
energy from
all the stars in our entire galaxy
at this point humans would have
harnessed biotechnology to its fullest
and
we would likely become a race of cyborgs
so advanced we'd be
indiscernible from robots our new
favorite dance move might be called
the human over the past decade
we've already developed electrode
implants that
allow amputees the ability to control
artificial limbs with their brains
we have brain implants that allow us to
hear
and perceive color and elon musk
is working on melding ai with the human
brain
with his company neuralink just
imagine where this techno evolution will
take us
in a million years to survive
warp speed travel we may very well have
to modify
our flesh and bone bodies into something
more resilient this is all wishful
thinking though
as a.i improves exponentially
robots will rapidly outsmart and
outnumber humans
they might consider us to be too useless
whiny and well obsolete
if we're lucky they'll keep us around as
pets or
wildlife or we may have to start
acting more like them ridding ourselves
of
any emotion or moral conscience
at this point ai would be
self-replicating on an
exponential scale and could strip a
planet with
little remorse for whatever creatures
live there
i'm sorry guys but you all know our
slogan
we are the board and resistance is
futile
oh hey i was just watching
curiositystream.com
you know luckily with curiositystream
there's a ton of interesting topics to
explore before we all become
super intelligent cyborgs or zoo animals
for robots
looking for a deeper dive into the world
of dinosaurs
interested in settling on an exoplanet
or maybe answer your cup of tea well
with curiosity stream you can watch
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals there's
truly something for everyone with topics
covering science
nature history technology lifestyle and
more
whether you like to learn on the go or
fetch out on the couch
curiosity stream supports many different
platforms and is available worldwide
as a subscription-based service you can
get unlimited
access starting at just 299 a month or
19.99 a year
to help you get started on your learning
journey go to curiositystream.com
what if and get unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
use the promo code what if and get it
completely free for the first 30 days
with almost limitless resources as a
type 3 civilization
we would have enough power to harness
planck energy
the energy of space-time physics at this
level would be
vastly different from what we know today
according to einstein's theory of
relativity
our ability to travel faster than light
is impossible
but at the planck scale we could build a
wormhole to get around
as a type 3 civilization with an
almost infinite energy supply we
wouldn't need
resource management at this point we'd
be godlike with enough
biotech to make us immortal and nearly
indestructible
if anything stood in our way well we
could
snap our fingers and call it a day
over time we would eventually exhaust
our
entire galaxy's resources in this case
we'd need to advance to become a type 4
or
5 civilization to explore and harvest
energy from
the rest of the universe without a
resource limit as a type four
civilization
we'd have no reason to value the
universe around us beyond our own
technological gains in other words we'd
get pretty bored
like getting 100 completion in your
favorite video game
on the most challenging setting so
what now don't worry we've got
a lot more in store before the robots
take over
as always that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
you